Next, let's dig into some mesh optimizations.
So the first thing we want to talk about is some system units.
So no matter what DCC you use, you just
need to make sure your system units are set up
before creating items.
We mostly use 3ds Max for this example,
but it applies to whatever DCC you're using.
In Unreal, we use centimeters for its default unit
of measurement.
So having the right scale is a good user experience.
The wrong side or mismatched scales
can break any immersion you have built, especially in VR.
So making sure you keep system units in mind
is a good way to start.
And then we're looking at draw calls.
So Unreal Engine's mobile renderers
are efficient at rendering large numbers of vertices.
So draw calls are what you need to optimize
if you've got a lot of rendered meshes in your scene.
So the image here shows how having a different material
assigned to different sets of triangles
will give an additional draw call.
So the more materials you have in your scene,
the more draw calls you'll have.
So your aim is to have no more than 120 draw calls on high
and 50 on low.
It's a rough approximate, but obviously your mileage
may vary there.
And when we're looking at normal mapping of meshes,
on the lower end hardware, normal maps
can be used to greatly enhance the quality of reflections
and lighting on the surface of the material.
However, subtle shapes like body panels on a car
can exceed the 8-bit deltas normally used for these maps,
which results in visible banding on the final render.
So you can use 16-bit normal maps to compensate for this,
but the pixel costs for the 16-bit normals
then extends the vertex cost of a higher density mesh.
So 16-bit normals are uncompressed in the engine,
which means they are also eight times the size
of a regular normal map there.
So it's a little bit hard to see the effect
that this has on reflection, but if we move into the next slide
here, you can see how jagged the reflection is when
it's on versus being off.
So it's useful to keep these settings in mind
in your projects.
And then we'll also lastly just talk about
limiting overdraw in our projects.
So overdraw is something that comes up
when dealing with transparency or opacity,
and it refers to your GP having to draw a mesh,
draw a bunch of transparent see-through areas, sorry,
that do not display on the texture information.
So you tend to find this a lot on foliage,
which you can see here, and it has the leaves map
to the different planes.
All pixels must be evaluated,
even the ones that show nothing.
So this will cause the GPU to do a lot of extra work
that it just has to disregard.
It doesn't actually result in anything.
So we want to limit by doing some of the following steps.
So you want to see that you can limit the amount
of transparent objects that overlap.
So by optimizing your mesh like this,
you can imagine if there was many different cards
of foliage all on top of each other,
and you had a card here,
well, it wouldn't be trying to render through something.
Whereas on the left-hand side,
you may have something on the bottom right-hand side there,
and it might be trying to render the first pass
and then render the pixels behind that.
So you want to limit the amount
of transparent objects that overlap.
And then you can see that you can get away with using geo here
instead of having the transparency.
So add the extra vertices to the meshes
so that they fit the transparency information better.
That'll be the best approach moving forward with foliage.
So you can use the shader complexity view modes,
which I'll touch upon in a second,
and you can see how bad overdraw may be.
But no matter how hard you try,
you'll not completely eliminate overdraw.
So don't waste too much time trying,
but it's just good to keep these mesh practices in mind
when you're first creating your assets.
So just try and limit as much as possible
and just follow these steps
as you go through the mesh creation process.